die lufthansa hat für morgen fast alle
flüge an den drehkreuzen frankfurt
münchen und berlin gestrichen weil die
gewerkschaft verdi die rund 20.000
beschäftigten des lufthansa
bodenpersonals zum streik aufgerufen hat
130 tausend passagiere werden deshalb
wohl nicht in den urlaub fliegen können
anders als der gewerkschaftsboss der ist
nämlich im urlaub und wahrscheinlich ist
sein koffer auch mitgeflogen wegen
fehlender mitarbeiter kommen tausende
koffer im moment ja nicht an und werden
so schnell auch nicht gefunden unser
reporter jan henrik tobias begleitet
einen verzweifelten urlauber auf der
ebenso verzweifelten suche nach seinem
gepäck
[Musik]
unzählige urlaubskoffer an deutschen
flughäfen gestrandet verloren herrenlos
so auch der koffer des münchners philipp
b bild reporter jan henrik leffers
begleitet ihnen auf der schier
unendlichen suche nach seinem koffer er
hat mir geschrieben dass er seit zu dem
zeitpunkt waren es acht tage in new york
urlaub macht in diesem urlaub von einem
t shirt einer unterhose ein paar socken
lebt also quasi nur das was er anhat und
seinen koffer eben nicht bekam rückblick
am flughafen münchen beginnt philipp
dees reise und die seines koffers sein
gepäck gibt er auf und steigt in ein
flugzeug nach frankfurt am main von dort
geht es weiter nach new york philipp b
bekommt den flieger sein koffer jedoch
nicht denn pandemie bedingt sind
gepäckabfertigung zur mangelware an
deutschen flughäfen geworden auf den
reise an stunden im sommer sind die
flughäfen nicht vorbereitet einen koffer
von einem flugzeug ins nächste zu
bringen dafür ist häufig nicht genug
personal da doch philippi ist
vorbereitet installiert vor seinem
reiseantritt einen gps-sender im koffer
und kann diesen nun aus der ferne
lokalisieren und zwar hier am flughafen
frankfurt hier trifft philip bild
reporter jan hendrik dowe als erste
anlaufstelle zum lost and found schalter
der lufthansa gegangen hat dort
vorgetragen dass er seit zehn tagen
diesen koffer quasi vermisst dass der
hier in frankfurt steht das auf dem
iphone auch gezeigt wo dieser koffer
steht und gefragt ob man nun mit ihnen
dorthin gehen könne um den koffer dort
abzuholen die mitarbeiterin der
lufthansa war zwar sehr bemüht doch eine
vorgesetzte die sie dann fragte ob sie
quasi mit dem fluggast philipp dorthin
gehen könne wurde aus der führungsebene
abgelehnt die lufthansa mitarbeiterin
ist verzweifelt berichtet den beiden
männern von den desaströsen zuständen am
flughafen
wir haben kein personal wir haben jeden
tag mindestens zehn krankmeldungen das
ist kein service mehr was man hier
bieten kann da stehe ich nicht mehr
dahinter bild erfährt wer nach 17 uhr in
frankfurt um steigt für dessen gepäck
gibt es keine mal mehr die koffer
stranden zwangsläufig philipp gibt nicht
auf wenn lufthansa nicht hilft muss die
bundespolizei her und es klappt die
beamten bringen philipp und jan-hendrik
in den sicherheitsbereich am terminal 2
hier bietet sich ihnen ein unfassbares
bild unzählige koffer gestapelt den
regalen unmengen an urlaubs koffer
gepackt für den sommerurlaub
verschwunden im hochsicherheitsbereich
des flughafens frankfurt am main hier
mitten im chaos findet philipp sein
gepäckkoffer und besitzer endlich wieder
vereint
doch so viel glück wie philipp haben die
wenigsten deutschen urlauber bild weiß
bis die gepäckstücke ihrem eigentümer
ausgehändigt werden kann es bis ins
kommende jahr dauern
[Musik]
was für eine geschichte und wir sind
noch mal mit jan hendrik dowe verbunden
der philipp dort begleitet hat auf
dieser odyssee und ja so viel glück
haben nicht viele haben wir gerade
gehört aber du hat dass das dann auch
der nur selbst 38 tage nach deinen
gepäck gesucht und im zuge der suche
nach philips koffer hast du auch deinen
gefunden erzählt uns die geschichte
ja primär wie gesagt war ich an den
flughafen eigentlich um diese koffer
suche mit dem gps sender von philipp zu
begleiten und an einem dieser orte den
wir angesteuert haben habe ich dann eben
auch versucht mein glück zu finden und
das war in meinem fall das sammel gepäck
lager das soll so heißt es so schön ein
ort wo eben auch gestrandet das gepäck
von der lufthansa zwischengelagert wird
und mein koffer hatte gar nichts mehr
dran normalerweise sind daher
gepäckbänder und irgendwelche barcodes
dran es war einfach nichts dran aber
tatsächlich das erste modell was auf die
beschreibung meines kopfes passe und ich
dachte ja das könnte passen hat geklappt
war ein volltreffer ja irre und gar
keine tags mehr dran also sozusagen
eigentlich gar keine chance mehr gewesen
den koffer jemals wieder zu ordnen zu
können ja eigentlich jetzt hat die auch
in dem sicherheitsbereich wir haben die
fotos gesehen in den ganzen regalen wie
hast du die situation dort wahrgenommen
genau man muss sich das so vorstellen du
sagst das ja richtig also es ist am ende
schon einen sicherheitsbereich da musste
ich auch ausweisen da reinzugehen und
das verwirrt schon wenn du da als
fluggast drin bist natürlich haben auch
koffer dort noch gepäckbänder also da wo
dann der barcode der name draufsteht
oder manchmal auch so namensschilder
aber am ende sind auch unzählige koffer
die einfach nichts haben wir mein koffer
auch und ich frage mich am ende wie kann
das sein dass ein so großer betrieb es
bei mir ja in 38 tagen nicht schafft
dass jemand das in irgendein ordnung
bringt also die lufthansa sagt mir auch
auf anfrage dass dort alles intern
registriert wird und dass dort quasi
eine ordnung bestehe nur für mich als
fluggast war die nicht ersichtlich
jan-henrik du was vielen dank für deine
schilderung
[Musik]